as a drummer I've always been fascinated
by the power of rhythm
that's the heartbeat of Music the
driving force that moves us
I've spent my life exploring percussion
and pushing the boundaries of what's
possible with sticks and skins but
there's another kind of beat that's been
around for centuries one that's not
played on drum but on a different kind
of instrument
the human body
questions
this is beatboxing the art of creating
Rhythm and sound using only the human
voice
as a drummer I'm fascinated by this art
form and how it compares to what I do
can the human body really compare to the
power of a drum kit
Arthur and I are going to meet with
beatboxers from across the country to
better understand the history of
Beatboxing and its impact on music today
thank you
all right
so I'm meeting up with Carnage The
Executioner today uh a beatboxing Legend
here in Minneapolis oh he's been all
over the world though he's been touring
the world I got my drums with me today
we're gonna get in here and create I'm
very excited to work with cars I've
played with him a few times before uh
Jam sessions here and there but today is
going to be special oh there he is what
am I
good to see you it's been too long bro
oh
what are some common misconceptions
about the boxing that you run into one
is that it's not music a lot of them say
is making noises with your mouth a lot
of people don't lead first foot forward
saying music
I I disagree I think that noises are
musical too you know every instrument
makes a noise and it's turned into music
foreign
is that not everybody can learn how to
beatbox
but anybody can learn how to turn
themselves into an instrument and that's
what I believe beatboxing is it's the
art of transforming your body into an
instrument
the art of creating music with your
mouth throat and body goes back to
ancient times but the culture of
Beatboxing as we know it didn't emerge
until the 1970s and 80s back then the
word beatbox was used to describe drum
machines like the cr7030 or the
legendary tr-808 so when early Pioneers
started mimicking drum sounds with their
mouths that became known as human
beatboxing
right now we're in New York City the
birthplace of Beatboxing but we're gonna
travel across the Hudson River to Jersey
City to visit the beatbox house a
collective of beatboxers who have won
multiple World battle championships the
band originated in Brooklyn over a
decade ago and is made up of five core
members Jean shinazaki Kenny Urban
Napalm Amit and Chrysalis the boundary
pushing group says they aim to Rebrand
the art form the notion that I have is
that you started the group is that
correct okay so how did you start the
group basically we wanted a place where
people could come who would beatbox you
know to beatbox
you know we we would see each other at
every competition you know we would
consistently be in like the top five so
we were like
let's form a group yeah you know you
start doing this thing it's really weird
by yourself but you know you really
enjoy it and you just keep doing it and
you want to find other people like that
[Music]
though the members of beatbox House made
their name by winning world battle
titles they told me that their focus has
changed to making original music and
exporting American beatbox culture to
other parts of the world
what we're doing now is producing music
basically right we're making these
electronic tracks but instead of
Gene picking a synth to use and pitching
it we're just using
and then boom
what are some misconceptions that people
have about beatboxing that it's a party
trick that's like the biggest thing
people are like oh that's a cool party
trick you do a sound and like oh it's
cool party trick but what we're doing is
trying to show people that beatboxing is
music
today beatboxing is an international
Phenomenon with a global battle scene
that pulls in millions of viewers online
and beatboxing can be found in the
recordings of hip-hop songs
[Music]
it's even made its way into songs
outside of hip-hop like this one from
Tom York
so how did the art of Beatboxing grow to
become so influential
it all started during the early days of
hip-hop back then beatboxing became an
alternative to drum machines which were
not very affordable early beatboxers
learned to mimic the sounds of drums
when a drum machine wasn't available
beatboxers accompanied MCS on the
streets during cyphers on stage at a
show and even in recorded songs
we like the party we don't cause trouble
we don't bother nobody where but
beatboxing didn't stay the accompaniment
eventually it became the main attraction
Pioneers like Dougie fresh Buffy from
The Fat Boys and Biz Markie would take
beatboxing to new heights by
incorporating beatboxing both on stage
and in the studio the track Lady by
Dougie fresh and Slick Rick became an
instant classic in one of the most
sampled tracks in hip-hop history
how was beatboxing important to the
history and culture of hip-hop it's the
instrument that
you always have on you it's the easiest
way to be a part of hip-hop culture
a lot of people now say beatboxing isn't
just hip-hop it's EDM it's dance music
blah blah but I still feel like
beatboxing is still
hip-hop because for me hip-hop isn't
just a style of music it's uh it's a
culture and beatboxing kind of it's
stemmed from that that culture of like
you know uh people being oppressed and
trying to speak out and express
themselves and beatboxing is a form of
expression you know
as the art form of Beatboxing grew more
artists began contributing by innovating
and creating new techniques artists like
Kenny Mohammed Rozelle wise D cross kid
lucky and many many more kid lucky
specifically was an important mentor and
teacher for other rising beatboxers in
the scene by the 90s beatboxing was well
known even Queen Latifah got her start
beatboxing for the group ladies fresh as
beatboxing grew in popularity an
underground battle scene began to emerge
Kenny Muhammad and razel became stars in
the battle scene this health
beatboxing's popularity spread overseas
where competitions popped up across the
world
I got to meet some of the best Battlers
in the world the members of the beatbox
house all got their start by Rising
through the ranks of the international
battle scene well the Main Avenue for
beatboxing is the competition especially
with a lot of young kids like they want
to get into this thing and they see that
that's the lane so it's like okay let me
invest my time into like learning how to
do that because that's what we did like
our goal is like let's win World Champs
like let's win Grand beat box battle and
we did
[Music]
beatboxing became a sensation online
where battle videos and YouTube
tutorials help bring beatboxing to
millions of new fans as the community
continues to grow there are more and
more women taking over the scene and
winning titles like Kayla Milady DJ
Hershey pechinkata and many more
Napalm has dozens of battle titles so I
couldn't pass up the opportunity to ask
him for a quick beatbox lesson okay I'm
so nervous to ask but can you teach me
how to do something something easy I am
a singer but like I am not a beatboxer
the basic one is boots and cats so
there's three sounds okay food
so the first one is the B you just gotta
make a hard B sound so like whoo
do that like five times
like precisely okay and then
so it's like a T and S together so if
you go
and then add a little
after
the last one is the cast so we'll see
you wear a k sounds so just
yeah
like that pretty much perfect you just
want to try to put some more energy into
that feel that
so now we're gonna put the three sounds
together boots and cats and yeah keep it
going keep it going
nice okay
so we know how beatboxing got its start
but I still want to know how it Stacks
up to someone playing the drums so to
put it to the test I challenge Carnage
to a friendly game of horse okay so I
was thinking the idea would be like a
kind of like a game of horse call and
response you do something and I try to
replicate what you do on here okay let's
do that for a couple minutes and then
let's switch it around
foreign
[Music]
who you feel like it's harder for a
beatboxer to emulate the drum sounds or
a drummer to emulate the beatboxing
sound you're probably thinking it's it's
as hard for you as I'm thinking it is
for me exactly because for me I feel
like there's certain stuff my mouth
can't do and you're probably thinking
well my hands can't do with his mouth
because that's not a double kick that's
like a trip or whatever it is
thank you
today beatboxing lives within
and Beyond is hip-hop beginnings
origin story is about making do with
what you have
and that's why it's become such an
Innovative art form
the Innovative Spirit of Beatboxing is
what has kept it around for over 40
years
and why it's sure to live on into the
future
go I want to let you know about fight
the power how hip-hop changed the world
a new PBS series hosted by hip-hop
Legend Chuck D it's about how hip-hop
became a global movement that spoke
truth to power check out the link in the
description below and let them know
soundfield sent you
Excel and you're now watching
[Music]